hey this is pressure Walker this puzzle
is making the rounds on Facebook in fact
one of the times it was posted it was
shared more than 400,000 times the
puzzle is can you fix the equation six
plus four equals four by moving exactly
one matchstick in these puzzles there
are typically some ground rules you
cannot break any of the sticks you must
make a valid equation with an equal sign
and in this particular problem you
should restrict yourself to numbers that
you can display using seven segments
these are the block numbers from 0 to 9
can you figure it out give it a try
before watching the rest of the video
for a solution so one way you can solve
this problem is by making the equation 0
plus 4 equals 4 you take this matchstick
and rotate it 90 degrees to make the
number 0 so you end up with the valid
equation 0 plus 4 equals 4 there's also
another solution you can make the
equation 8 minus 4 equals 4 to do that
you take this stick from the plus sign
and join it to the 6 now you have 8
minus 4 equals 4 which is also valid
these are the two solutions I know are
there any other solutions let us know in
the comments thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch around my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there links in
the video description